what is going on guys welcome to the
next part in the last part in the
shantae momentum oscillator tutorial
mini-series within our Python stocks and
mathematics grand series where we left
off we were calculating the CMO within
Python now it's actually chart up the
CMO within Python if you don't already
have the starter code please visit the
link in the description scroll down just
a bit to sample code with empty slot
click on that bad boy and here is where
the sample code is so just go ahead and
highlight it scroll all the way down
copy that
this is side and paste it into like an
empty script here so I'll paste this one
and in this code we will do all the
editing if you scroll up a little bit I
may be a little too little comments all
the programming goes in between these
little two comments here to make things
nice and easy for you guys so once you
have that go back to where we actually
programmed this and you want to just
take the entire calculation we don't
need this but basically this all the way
up to the top of where we define CMO
copy that come back over to this script
and we would not only put it at top but
I might not bother doing that right now
we're gonna go all the way down here and
just paste it right in here now we need
to fix our indent so come on peer indent
and then and now we're fixed on the end
then lastly let me go ahead and align
this on on the screen right okay so now
the indicators here it's being called
I'm gonna go ahead and say see mocks for
X seam away for Y then we're gonna go
ahead and do a X 2 dot fly and see mocks
and then we always do a minus SP : if
you want to know why I check out the
charting stocks in python tutorial
series si muy - s tu and then finally we
want it to be a white line then we're
going to go ahead and do plot y label
and we're gonna say this is a CMO 10
and the color is white of that text so
that should be all we need to do so
let's go ahead and run it and that
should bring up this will plot apple
again here and here is our chart with
with just the line now if you recall in
the other video that I was showing you
guys we had a horizontal line here
another line here and then we also I was
going to show you and at the zero mark
there was a line and I was also going to
show you the simple moving average stuff
so let's go ahead and do that so it'll
kind of be like this RSI line up here so
now that we've done that let me just
close out of this and we're gonna go
ahead and add those horizontal lines
first so to do that it's just pretty
simple it's ax 2.8 X H line where do you
want that H line at the 50 what color do
you want to be that's a red right so
that would indicate an overbought
situation I'm just going to do paste
paste here this will be a zero this will
be a negative 50 this will be a green
and then we'll just make this a white so
this would be the oversold
scenario and then just kind of like that
neutral line so now let's go ahead and
plot that again we'll chart up an apple
again and so now you see that we have
the colored horizontal lines now the
last thing I want to show you guys is
how to apply that simple moving average
to this line so let's go ahead and do
that so let's just do that
underneath this y label definition and
what we're gonna say is SMA cig or the
signal line equals moving average see
mauve 20 if you don't know how to make a
simple moving average this is
referencing a function that we've built
in this charting application right here
not only is this covered in our Python
charting stocks tutorial series I also
do have a video covering that simple
moving average in this series as well if
you want to know more about that
otherwise we're just gonna call it we're
gonna give it you know we're going to
use it
oops this should be
the wide line the sigmoid and we're
gonna apply it's 20 simple moving
average to it and then we're going to go
ahead and plot it so we're going to say
X 2 dot fly see mocs SMA cig and again
we want to do that - SP : - it here as
well - I spent : and then we are gonna
change the color to see for cyan save
that run that again a lot of Apple since
that's what we've been using and now
we've applied a 20 simple moving average
to that line as well use it like a
signal 1 so that's going to conclude the
Sean a momentum oscillator tutorial
video miniseries here hopefully you guys
enjoyed hopefully you learn something
new as always thanks for watching things
for all the support and subscriptions
and until next time